[Music]
all right hey what's going on it's bill
burr and it's time for a very special
episode of the thursday afternoon just
before friday monday morning podcast and
when i say
i have a special episode that means i
have a special guest and i have had a
lot of special guests
over the years here on this podcast but
i don't think anybody gets more special
than this guy
local legend yes the greatest
professional wrestler to come out of the
new england area please welcome thrilly
dilly
the one man thrill ride to the thursday
afternoon just before friday monday
morning podcast what's going on what's
up bill it's been a long time since we
hung out and like this me too movement
man it's changed a lot of things
um
it's uh it's going in hot yeah
absolutely and this me too movement like
i have this new mandatory policy right
anytime i meet up with one of my bumble
breezies and bring them back to the
smash factory uh for you know a
25-minute thunderclap session
all sexual activity needs to be filmed
in full 8k to confirm consent and it's
an awkward conversation but don't get me
wrong i have like a 10 terabyte hard
drive that would put bang bros out of
business shout out to my exes yup that
was easy
all right so there you go that's going
to be the energy
that we're going to be coming with here
we're going to uh we're going to plow
ahead here you know one of the great
characters got to tell you something i
first discovered you uh on the internet
when you were doing your baseball promos
yes talking about your laser light show
rounded second base while your
girlfriend's looking at me yeah yeah you
got a sunken in chest i could eat a bowl
of soup out of or cereal or something
like that and i was just like who the
hell is this guy and just as a comedian
and a fan of wrestlers
and the over-the-top uh personalities i
immediately became a fan so i am
thrilled to have the throw right here on
my podcast i appreciate it bill
um
and that's the one thing that we hung
out at ruff and rowdy and since then
like the pandemic hit i mentioned that
the terabyte hard drive you know i have
2569 hours of explosive sexual content
and during the pandemic i had an
opportunity to isolate and go through
each and every scene and put them into
distinct categories like for instance
like squirters
which of course are all of them
shout out to my exes so
i didn't i didn't get him on that one
no i'm fascinated by your life that
you're living here yeah the thrill throw
ride can go for a while huh i think so i
mean the way i wrestle i i'm a retro guy
i'm a retro electro guy that's my theme
music i used to have the absolute savage
look now i'm miami vice because that's
that's more who i am i watch those
austin a e documentaries about um you
know it starts off it was so captivating
he goes you know what's the difference
between steve austin and stone cold he's
like well the difference between steve
austin is still cold and nicky pause
he's like [ __ ] son i don't know the
difference yeah so i'm like that's where
i'm at i'm just being myself now you
know
so okay favorite car from the 80s when
you were coming up oh god
am i going too far back because i'm old
as [ __ ] yeah you're not in 84. like oh
84. [ __ ] all right favorite car the 90s
uh yeah so what if what are you so you
were born in the 80s i was born in the
80s yeah you're wearing the hat looks
like miami vice like two years after you
were born so how did that happen older
brother no no i was the oldest in the
family i was just i always loved old
school wrestling i grew up in fox bro
well i grew up in mansfield moved over
to foxborough and lived with my uncle
joe and my grandmother for a little
while and like he was a die-hard
wrestling fan and he had you know every
single pay-per-view that was on vhs so
like i got into wrestling watching like
the 80s stuff and oh wow yeah so
now did you ever go
yeah
so the whole i i wrote that i wrote a
movie and uh the opening scene is you
know tickets to the survivor series in
1993 uh which was in the last
pay-per-view in the boston garden
survivor series wow and then i went to
the 2000 uh king of the ring tournament
um when kurt angle won it and the rock
on the belt and then this weekend i
worked with kurt angle
and drove did you really yeah well sort
of so i introduced him
it was probably
the loudest pop i've ever heard in pro
wrestling when he came out and i was in
the center of the ring for it was one of
my heroes growing up so it was a real
cool experience and then but if you know
anything about wrestling without
teaching wrestling school is it's more
important to get kurt angle to the
airport in time than it is to have a
good segment with him
so i'm in the car right i got sergeant
slaughter in the front seat and kurt
angle in the back seat the all-american
meat missile driving it was the most
american car ride in the history of
professional wrestling
we're in traffic from newark uh from new
jersey trying to get to the newark
airport and i pull into the freaking
hotel and kurt angle and we're having a
great conversation kurt and i and then
all of a sudden he like kind of kind of
started pissing he's like dude i'm
supposed to go to the airport it was
like a miscommunication i don't know i
was like [ __ ] he was like [ __ ] man we
got a guy i was like i do not want
nuclear i got the more heat with
everybody in pro wrestling like the last
thing i want is heat with guard angle
so i'm like sarge i need your brother
and exercise no worries i know how to
get there so i've been in this city 700
times you know what i mean like thank
god for sergeant slaughter he's like got
to guide me we got kurt there in time
but you know they don't tell you that in
wrestle what is it like riding in the
car with those two guys i mean those are
two guys you grew up watching i remember
sergeant slaughter yeah from way back
what was what was his his wasn't the
cobra clutch was it i think it was a
cobra the coco
yeah everybody had like that big
finishing move he was one of the legends
but then he used the the
um
cheeks move the camel clutch when he
turned heel against america during the
iraq war he used the camel clutch so
yeah he was evil i know but that was a
great story it's an unbelievable
storyline so
i don't know
there's a lot of wrestling now like
roman reigns you know he's like the best
wrestler in the world he calls himself
he is he doesn't just call himself he is
the head of the table like i don't know
anything about that but i do know
something about head at the table
because i'm the guy bringing blowies
back to the business of professional
wrestling
i don't know how i don't have a job
because i'll go out there i'll lose
first i want to be on first everybody
else wants to steal the show i want to
go on first
we'll crush it i'm going to the bar on a
solo dolo mission okay if i take the
sunnies off and flash the baby blues
across the bar
break out the wet floor signs because
she's going to be sweating like a you
know what i mean she's just going to be
pouring sweat
the baby blue laser show it's over the
chicks are all gonna come over fellas
you're welcome for the house come on
over once the show's over you can hang
out with them because those eights are
low grade hot i got a new york giants
cheerleader sitting in the marriott
waiting to receive an injection of
genetic perfection and ride the meat
missile into outer space shout out to my
axes available on oneman thrillride.com
give me your money
puppets
i don't understand my exes probably all
think that i'm talking about them and
i'm talking about all of them
ex-employers ex-friends
everybody who didn't believe in me i'm
throwing up the shocker because i can't
throw up the middle finger
so tell me you but you you were actually
to the point right you have an amazing
story would you i'm actually interested
you know you said you wrote a script i
would love to see that thing get made
but yeah um of you you basically you
came out of high school you immediately
went into wrestling yep and then you got
out you did the baseball thing we had
bridgewater fitchburg's day fitchburg
stay sorry jesus christ i'm going to
cause a war here
fitchburg state rock school all right so
you went to fitchburg state then you got
back into it so as a comedian kind of
knowing what it's like at least in my
business to come out of nowhere nobody
knows you what are wrestling open mics
what what is that so what would what
went down was so i got trained by spike
and um you know spike was the man ecw
legend spike dudley and um you know so
when i started he wanted to be this like
white meat baby face you know what i
mean like ricky steamboat and lex luger
he was he was like i want you to be a
combination of ricky steamboat lex luger
and this is the ultimate spike line i
said uh
i thought i loved lex i was like wasn't
lex like not a very good worker and he
looked at me and he goes i don't know
how about we look at his [ __ ] bank
account and i was like
i'm like all right i'll be lex i'll
relax
so um so not a good workers they're not
selling what you're doing uh no like a
not a good worker would be like somebody
who's not a good in-ring performer but
it depends who you ask but they're to me
a good worker is somebody who like hulk
hogan i think's a phenomenal worker
because everybody you know he he can
wrestle if you watch him over in japan
and then you can if you wrestle in
america all he has to do is this right
and he gets the biggest reaction but if
you watch him you know wrestling in
japan are really going you know he can
actually go and that's sort of as i've
gotten older this is why i think i can
last a long time is
it's i sound like you know i've watched
too many terry bella shoot interviews
but you know i hit a shoulder tackle and
i just go yup
and the crowd's like
yup like step brothers like we just
became best friends and i'm like well
that got a better reaction that tackle
so i'm just going to keep going up yup
yup and start strutting and like
so that you learn so when you build the
character you do that in the ring as
it's happening sort of doing like the
promo things you improv a few things
here or there yeah cause i remember
seeing something one time the the rock
was talking about he did something
and uh somebody said like yeah that
really annoyed the crowd he goes yeah
good i'm gonna keep doing that i'm gonna
go like in that direction i remember
thinking like wow these guys are like
stand-up comics yes well the heels are i
feel like where it's like you're not
trying
you're almost trying to annoy see how
long you can annoy them and they're
still coming along for the ride yes
and make the baby face want to beat the
sh like they want to see the baby face
just beat the [ __ ] out of you that's
like the good heel and then like being a
good heel worker is about you know
making the baby face look like a million
dollars so but anyway like for me it's
you know
when i basically learned that it was
from like billy gunn so as i got old i
saw rough and rowdy happen and i decided
i lost the fight and it bothered me for
about i would say an hour and then i
went to the bar in charlotte and i
realized like i was the absolute meat
missile and the
man you also fought in uh that's the
house of rick flair built right yes yeah
i got to go back to that i want to do a
stand-up show there yeah we were playing
this old uh the people listen watching
here it was this old old-school wrestle
arena wrestling arena and it was just
like perfect like literally built for it
and it had almost like this short porch
up top that was like the upper deck and
everybody was just on top of you and i
remember you know
i mean i was there for that rough and
rowdy it was you fought great i mean
it's just you know somebody wins
somebody loses but like the just the
energy the crowd and everything like
that i literally felt like i was uh
on like you know like one of those
saturday morning wrestling things that i
used to watch back in the day with like
the moon dogs and
uh the wild samoans and all of that
stuff so um
let me ask you this what's the uh
when you get into the ring with somebody
who sucks you don't have to name any
names yeah and they're going for some
big move where if they [ __ ] up they
could literally break your neck right
what is that like are you talking to him
so i would not do anything with somebody
who sucks says there's a test first how
quick before yeah how quick before you
realize they suck so if i don't know
somebody you do this test you're like
hey man i just let's start it off with
like a good tie up when we get out there
like really because that's how you know
if a guy who doesn't know how to
freaking do a good tie up a good lock up
he sucks
so it's like so let's like just try this
once and we're in the locker room and
like we go to freaking tie up and if
he's all over the place or too snug i'm
like this kid sucks we're not doing
anything he wants he's not gonna be safe
but if he snaps the tie up right it's
like okay he's been trained properly so
then how do you communicate to him
because are you really gonna say in the
locker room like all right dude you're
gonna hurt me so let me let me run this
thing dude some of these freaking
matches it's like a hostage negotiation
you know
and it's you're calling these things but
um as you so like i worked enzo and
probably the biggest match of my life
a month ago and like enzo's a big league
all-star made money drew money and like
we were like
we didn't call anything we called it on
the fly we were on last it was like what
are you like he i had three he had three
big moves i watched his matches i fed
him a couple spots but he came up with
the finish and i he goes what do you do
i'm like i honestly nothing i talk [ __ ]
punch and kick
you know because is there anything you
want to get in i said yeah there's one
thing i want to get in i want to go on
the second rope i'm going to g up for a
uh 1989 rick rubin forearm to the back
i'm going to say step brothers yup yup
yup i'm going to hit you with a rickroad
forearm like we're back in the 80s boom
and i'm going to pose for seven seconds
in front of the hard camera throw up the
double shocker which represents two in
the pink one in the stink and scream at
the top of my lungs shout out to my exes
and enzo says to me he just goes stops
and goes dude that's [ __ ] money
it is it's because the amount of people
that i know that are watching if they're
dying laughing half the reason why i'm
dying laughing is just knowing the
people that that's going to annoy like
right really really bill in 2021 is this
what we're doing
it's just i don't know i i
i i
i've always loved the heels when i was a
little kid i couldn't stand them because
i thought they cheated and everything
but once i got to a certain age and i
realized
you know
i you know started annoying teachers how
much fun it was and i saw that these
guys were like professionals at doing it
um i just totally fell in love
with the uh with the whole thing i wish
it would like kind of get back to where
it was
in my life it had like i felt like three
peaks yep it was like when i first saw
it in the late 70s
and it was sort of the end of bob
backlund bruno san martino hey stacks
callum those guys were getting you know
old or whatever backland wasn't all
though and then uh andre the giant yep
ivan putski all those guys right and
then it was hulk hogan yeah uh mr
wonderful leicester's soul all of those
guys came in
for that that big time wrestlemanias all
the way through and then it went away
for a little bit i started doing
stand-up and then it came back
with the rock and all of those guys um
mankind yep and the undertaker and all
of that type of stuff and i feel like
it's you know it's it's almost like
comedy like comedy kind of does that had
like the big 80s then i started doing
stand-up and everything was like right
in the toilet
and oddly enough 911 kind of brought it
back everybody needed to like laugh or
something like that and then we've kind
of gone on this this sort of real estate
bubble yeah with social media we're
selling tickets so um any predictions
yeah as far as where it's going i
honestly think it's about to go through
the next golden era within i would say
in another year we're going to see a
huge burst in popularity pro wrestling
due to the rise in popularity of all
elite wrestling they're on tbs and tnt
uh cody rhodes is there tony kahn who's
the son of the uh jacksonville jaguars
uh owner i thought you would say kill a
con no not a killer tony khan tony cohen
all right so like they're you know i i
worked on the show in mid hudson for
northeast wrestling on this weekend and
you know a bunch of all elite guys were
there
um so you know they're making a pretty
big splash and like you know they're
they're straight up competition with wwe
and the last time there was competition
it was the monday night wars really with
wcw and wwf at the time
uh and that's when the attitude era
happened the rock and steve austin took
over so i think it's gonna cause the wwe
to have to adapt right and which will be
great for wrestling and now there's more
jobs and that was like
so in 2019 was sort of when i started
turning the corner in wrestling i worked
a big cast when he was straight off tv
he was main event with daniel bryan on
pay-per-view like three to six months
prior right and i worked with him all
summer and at the end of the summer like
one night he was like i was supposed to
rest with somebody else and he goes hey
i just talked to mike me and you were
working in the main i was like he's the
man great guy cass is a man
and um i worked with him at the end of
the tour he's like dude you got to try
to get down to performance center and
try to get get a job he goes you're
definitely good enough it's like and i
was just like i don't know man i got you
know i was close and i got burnt and it
was my fault i'm looking back at it and
i take full responsibility for not
getting let's that [ __ ] happens yeah
yeah it broke my heart
[ __ ] oh my god dude that [ __ ] just like
sometimes they feel like if you like are
the guy but you don't just fit you know
the suit or whatever you just gotta know
that all right i guess i go the long way
around i got a bunch of buddies mine
like that i gotta look at us we're
[ __ ] regular bald looking guys we
gotta take the we're not in the express
lane right we got to go the long way
around and then when we get there we
still got to listen to people yeah you
know you got there easy
you know doors flew open for you it's
just what people
it's just it is what people do but you
you sent me an email and you had some uh
you had some classic stories that i want
to make sure uh that i i don't know
which one to start with my all-time
favorite one's the jake roberts story
all right uh jake the snake jake the
snake
and but before anybody gets on with me
with this story please listen to the end
because
jake roberts all i gotta say is that guy
[ __ ]
yes
so
it's for big time wrestling in 2013 i'm
working with my friend teddy in a tag
match with uh jake and um oh i can't tom
brandy so he's uh he was salvador
sincere and then he became uh the
patriot he bought the gimmick
yeah so
awesome like wrestling in the java civic
center in pittsburgh outside of
pittsburgh i want to say and i'm
wrestling jake in the tag match and i
know i'm taking his comeback and i'm
taking the ddt and like he's gonna i
know his whole comeback right it's like
he's a lot he's a southpaw it's like jab
jab jab big left feet up short arm
clothesline call for it [ __ ] ddt and
like the place goes nuts when he calls
for i'm like getting goosebumps thinking
about it like i'm so jacked up people
think like oh you're gonna lose i'm like
yeah i'm gonna [ __ ] get beat by jake
rob it's gonna be [ __ ] awesome you
know
so i'm getting ready i'm getting ready
and we heard that jake had just cleaned
up he had substance abuse problems
so we show up in the building and like
where's jake
jake's in the other room
i'm like okay so we walk in there and
jake's like laid out on the couch like
drooling and we're like oh no
that's that's a shame
and then like it's time to call the
match and the whole day he's like oh
he's not talking to us he's like
drooling i'm like this is like really
sad
and i'm like i'll get him through it
i'll get him through the comeback when
he takes the hot tag i'll get him
through it so he's calling the match um
brandy's calling the match calling match
because jake's not going to get in
during the shine um you'll just come in
for the hot tag
what is during the shine no no excuse me
he is going to come in during the shine
what is the shine so it's like uh
for the baby face it's the beginning of
the match and the baby face beats up the
hill a little bit to show that he's the
superior wrestler okay so like
jake's gonna get in the ring for the
shine so just work with him and like
jake's drew and we're like are you sure
oh no
so then it's uh blah blah blah we call
it up and then it's time for the
comeback jimmy you want to emma's like
really you wanna and i'm like yeah sure
and then i go to i go to go to jake like
very gently all of a sudden he just pops
out of his seat like a gazelle and goes
all right jab jab jab big left i'm gonna
give you a short arm clothesline call
for ddt see out there kid and slash you
on the ass just walks away i was like
oh
[ __ ] he faked it
he faked the whole thing so he couldn't
get any offense on him and like we
weren't gonna get any offense on him
he's [ __ ] jake roberts you know what
i mean i'm like dude you didn't have to
work me it was [ __ ] hilarious so i
just turned to teddy i was like dude
that guy [ __ ] dude like that was it was
just badass he was like a gangster you
know what i mean like i'm like dude
that's how psyched are you i'm gonna i'm
gonna wrestle jake the snake in the java
center yeah outside of pittsburgh i mean
that's like the story you want yeah it
was awesome and then i i had like i
still get goosebumps think about it he
did that jab jab jab bomb and um he
called for it and i remember like
selling up and the way you don't jake
doesn't kick you and you do the ddt just
grabs you and drops you so like i was
just like selling up and the place was
going ballistic you know what i mean it
was one of my favorite movies in
wrestling and then like they're all
dirty
and then he hit me
and like everyone's like oh you're a job
or you're losing i just remember i was
like what
the place like came all over themselves
you know
i'm sorry so back in the day before like
this pc culture they compared pop in the
crowd to having sex with a chick and
getting her off that was like the
comparison if you can
you can judge how good it is
how good a guy was in the sack by how
good of a worker he was
yeah you know i mean look this there was
a bunch of [ __ ] that needed to be said
it wasn't said and then they were in the
adjustment yeah phase here so hopefully
people can tell the difference between
doing a character 100 percent and you
know but they won't they'll act like
this is some [ __ ] national geographic
serious [ __ ] about global warming how
could he say all of that what is my
password here what the [ __ ] is it i'm
trying to set you up here for them we'll
edit that part out all right now here's
another next one the nwo short rib story
all right oh the [ __ ] reb yeah you're a
foodie right yeah
oh [ __ ] rib not short rib [ __ ] rib wait
a minute so i don't know if this
actually happened but i could be totally
delusional in seeing ghosts
but i was at so the backstory of this
and i could be paranoid but i wrestled
cody hall scott hall son in a tag team
match for northeast wrestling in 2014
and we gave he had a great match right
like i was working with scott
and um you know i remember we had this
plan for the match and i and scott hall
was there and uh
i had heat with scott to start because
my this kid i
i guess he's my friend but
we're in the car with cody's son and
like he's like [ __ ] acting like we're
in high school like blowing me when i'm
in the back seat with cody in the front
like this guy's the best promo in
wrestling this guy's the best promo on
wrestling this guy's dude check out this
problem i'm like buddy please be quiet
you're gonna get me heat with scott hall
he's like in the illuminati of pro
wrestling he's one call away from triple
h who is second in command only to vince
mcmahon can you not can you just shut up
you're putting me in a bad spot
so i'm like we get to the arena and as
soon as we get there cody goes this guy
thinks he's the best promo on pro
wrestling i'm like
oh no [ __ ] it scott goes
so then like the joke is i started doing
my promo at the start of the match and
he was like this is bush and it was bush
because like i was doing my catchphrases
and like a 500
uh there was like 500 people there maybe
more because it was like a bigger show
and like they didn't know my
catchphrases because like you saved that
stuff for like your your monthly or
weekly show that operates like tv like
we do that at the bethany town hall so
they know your catch phrases you can
have a finishing move like all that
stuff but if you're doing like nobody
knows who i am i shouldn't be doing
catchphrases so it was bush yeah i know
but sometimes you just get it if
somebody does that shoulder bump and
goes yep yeah right i'm like ah what the
[ __ ] is that i like that right shout out
to my exes i don't need to be like
what's the back story right like i get
it this guy's being an obnoxious ass
right and trying to piss off yeah but my
point was like scott was like actually
had a great attitude the whole time he
just there was that one thing
and uh so anyway we're going to call the
match in the back and i was like we're
going to do a hot start and scott was
like i don't think that's a good idea
you guys it's the same midnight express
rock and roll express like you don't
have 10 weeks 10 months of tv behind
this i think you should just tie up i
was like and i thought about it i was
like well all right and he goes hey i
don't maybe i don't know what i'm
talking about they just threw up his
hall of fame ring
and i was just like
i'm like [ __ ] it we're doing what we're
doing razer says you know what i mean
like he knows what he's talking about
and then like we're about to go out and
like uh right before the match they do
this whip reverse spot knee to the back
back elbow we're match right we're not
paying attention we got dicks in our
hands and scott was the only one paying
attention it's razer razor ramon and he
turns around he goes uh hey just to know
they you they use your exact same
cut-off spot you guys need to think
about now like he was on his game
and before we got to the building cody
is this guy his son cody's like six foot
eight like a monster but he's a good
athlete which like works against him
like he was trying to do all these like
trying to go in the ring with scott and
he's like trying to do flips and stuff
and scott just looked at me and he goes
you just try to talk to him he won't
listen to his old man that's what he
said to me and i'm like dude your
money's in being a monster so like i was
like let me take the hot tag and you're
gonna beat me you know what i mean like
i don't want to put a tumblr no one
wants to see that no i was like the
money is in you look i'm dude i'm five
nine two ten with veins popping out of
my six pack doing backflips off the top
rope and you make me look like a [ __ ]
like i'm not gonna like dude like
crush me on the comeback you know what i
mean like and like he cody like
absolutely crushed it and so it's like
we hot tag whatever you know i can't
remember his bump feed but like he did
razor razor ramon's comeback you know
you know go for the high cross catch
sack of [ __ ] [ __ ] that's it calls for
the finish like razor wood
the two big lines the place is going
ballistic and like before the match
who's busting our balls because i love
folding up job guys i love folding up
job guys so
he's got me up for the razor's edge like
eight feet i'm like please don't hurt me
please don't hire me he [ __ ] drops me
flat back safest bump in the world one
damn place came all over himself scott
was so [ __ ] happy right because like
he saw his son like crush it
and he was like and he he talked to all
of us but he looked at me he goes this
job's for guys like you you know nice
and but then what happened was i don't
know what happened between and it's not
my business between scott and the
promoter but like
him and cody were never invited back and
i have no idea why and then this article
leaked on russell's own that went like
viral
that said he was like unprofessional
backstage
and i heard that it was because he said
i was like the promo was bush
and it was bush like what he said was
accurate and like it was good feedback
and like as friends like that was our
catchphrase we'd go to the bar the steak
would be undercooked this steak is bush
you know what i mean like we loved it
and like so like i don't know if that
was the source of the heat or whatever
so anyway rough and rowdy happens and
then i talked about my wwe tryout which
is a huge mistake
mistake so that happened and i'm working
in the brockton uh where the brockton
rocks play you just gotta take your
lumps and just know that everybody
whatever if you got 20 stories of
getting [ __ ] over someone else has got
like 21. right you know something else
too what happened with those guys were
doing whatever their took your opening
did the exact same thing i remember this
headliner a long time ago he goes i
always watch the whole show yeah because
i want to know what subjects are talked
about because if somebody just did a
whole [ __ ]
chunk on trump or or biden or something
and then you come up oh it's up with
biden people like oh god not not again
100 especially now too because
everyone's kind of doing the covet thing
which i i you know what's the worst i've
been doing this long enough that when i
don't watch the show and i go up there
as i bring the subject out i feel how
flat it is i'm like oh god yeah yeah
somebody already brought this this has
already been mulched up so
yeah turn into this subject over here so
but that's today's standard to put that
back to pro wrestling that's a great
point nowadays everything's so
choreographed like especially young kids
it's like they're calling every single
spot it's like
no no when you say calling it i almost
feel like at the end of this podcast you
got to let me know yeah you know heat
and all that and we'll just have little
definitions underneath you so people can
keep oh i don't want to do that because
then they'll be the freaking guys on the
contract would be that guys doesn't know
what the hell he's talking about
he's not burying me but you know what i
mean like it's the heat's when the you
know the the bad guys putting steam on
the on the good guy and get the
good guys trying to get sympathy you
know what i mean right right right and
sell and that's the mark of a good good
guy is his ability to sell and that's
like enzo
he sold like ricky morton from the rock
n roll express like he was so good at
that and everybody like oh enzo's just
can just cut a promo it's like now he's
a fantastic professional wrestler all
right well what do you got coming next
as far as like uh the next big one that
you're doing because i i can't say it
what i'm such a huge fan of the
character that you came up with
um i look at like wrestlers like they
are stand-up comedians when you get like
a really good one i mean i do it all the
time i sit there and i watch like i was
just watching a clip of me jean laughing
during promos
and then some just you know some of the
worst promos of all time and then the
best ones so i have such a respect for
what you guys do and then all the the
stuff you put your bodies through
um what is the uh cause i know you a
couple of times like you know i'm going
forward then uh [ __ ] this and i'm going
for it again the pandemic
blah blah blah blah you went through a
little you know funk funk there as we
all do yep i mean part of being a
performer is one day you're gonna be on
a couch and for some reason you can't
get up it's a sunny day and you're just
laying there like what the [ __ ] is going
on with me
uh it's all entertainers it's a yeah how
did you get through that by the way when
you went through your uh i wrote a movie
about what i was going through oh there
you go it was about i made it a comedy
you know
i just went through like a breakup with
this chick and it was like and and i got
talked um my my friend uh jamie silva
who's like one of the first guys to call
me after the alumni he played for the
indianapolis colts in super bowl 46 he
was like an all-american at bc
he did films and like jamie and uh patty
quinn who like did uh mass holes they
had this viral video [ __ ] people from
boston say oh i saw all those i love
those yeah so patty did the screen story
like he came up with the plot like i
just wrote it he was like this is the
outline this is act one this is act two
this act three so um yeah i'm just
explaining i had this idea for a movie
that was like a rocky parody about pro
wrestling and it was just basically me
and my friend mark sherman in the car
and he's like wait a minute he goes i i
showed up i was all flustered he was
like he's like what's going on with you
it was like just got a zoom therapy
session
just went through a breakup
i'm like crushed i was like in love with
this chick and she's with another guy
now blah blah blah
he's just like wait a minute you're the
[ __ ] one man thrill ride like what
the [ __ ] are you crying about it's like
you got like
you know what i mean he's like dude this
is the this is the movie he's like i'm
like are you sure i was like
he's like it absolutely is because
that's the interesting thing because the
watch you doing simping out all of that
[ __ ] yeah it's hilarious you know and
like no of course there's a freaking
therapist who's smoking hot which really
happened
well don't tell too much of it because
someone will [ __ ] steal it no no [ __ ]
but it's copywritten yeah yeah but still
yeah
yeah yeah you gotta watch out with that
stuff i kind of like i actually do i
either go to the gym yep if i'm when i
get like uh
depressed i either go to the gym
or i uh i try to do stand-up
and uh i just go down then i just be
nice to people yep not saying i'm not
nice but i just kind of extra nice like
hey how's it going i just i get out of
me like hey what's going on with you oh
that's great i'm really happy for you i
let people go when i'm driving i just
try to get because if i don't and i just
start going down at the i called you
know go down on the bottom of the lagoon
then you know i got a wife and two kids
now and uh you know that's so true
though when you do this with a guy you
can't have a bad day right you're not
allowed chicks can sit there be like oh
just kind of going through some things
and you it's just like they're just
looking at you like all right well maybe
if you go uh [ __ ] pick that box up
over there no you should yeah you'll
feel a little better it's called the
masks of masculinity it's just masking
emotional trauma like you've been like
this whole character is because i've
heard over chicks you know what i mean
that's you know that's all it is that is
you know what's funny the other day i
actually showed my therapy that i went
to yeah
all right you want to know what my i
can't even i'll tell you someday why i
actually do stand up people that's
because you love comedy is that why did
you always love comedy right it's like
no people were beating the [ __ ] out of
me yeah so i thought if i could get a
room make everybody laugh no one would
beat the [ __ ] out of me 100 that's what
it was i went on there with the with the
emotion of a four-year-old yeah and
that's what i did
through all of that and most of the [ __ ]
someday i'll tell the whole [ __ ]
story but uh this this this is uh
this is about your stuff so i always
find it amazing when someone is funny
electrifying got the whole thing and
then you got that whole other side where
you just [ __ ] laying there at the
bottom of the lagoon as i say but uh so
you had you went therapy so that's good
so you don't have because whenever i
hear people they got the chemical [ __ ]
yeah where it's like you can't like you
know no amount of [ __ ]
good times can bring you out of it you
just have to wait for uh almost you know
they got raw sewage just getting dumped
in the bay whatever that chemical is
that's going in like those people
like i i sometimes when i'm depressed i
think about them i go at least i have an
out right of this thing i don't have to
go like go get like meds
and then you know it's as it's pulling
you out what part of my body is it
[ __ ] up right i know it's crushing my
liver or whatever you know do you feel
like when you perform you get it out
if i do something new yeah and if i
connect with the crowd yes because
there's two ways like
there's two laughs there's the laugh
like okay that's funny and then there's
the uh dude i [ __ ] love that yeah
yeah and there's that's like a different
sounding laugh
and when i get that
especially too if um uh
if you know if there's there's levels of
of uh more feeling of a satisfaction yes
like if i'm from like you know in boston
all white crowd like me and i even if i
get that laugh it's cool right but like
when i'm in front of people who are
different yeah you know what i mean like
you're special in tennessee nashville
right yeah that was a good special do
something like that or like you know
back in the day you know they had like
the uptown show the gay show whatever if
you could get a laugh like that on that
night yep that was like that extra kind
of uh
special thing where that would get me
out of it and i'd be like all right i
can feel the next 20 minutes the
material's coming yeah i got something
to move forward to because i found out
in this pandemic that when i was just
like you know i think i'm gonna take
some time off right and i slowed down
and all this smoke caught up with me
yeah cause that's people you work like a
[ __ ] maniac right so you got such a
great work ethic it's like no i got
demons dude
it's 100 i'm just i'm just trying to
stay in front of these things so um is
there a match or anything coming up like
like covet has obviously affected you
guys and everything throughout all of
this it was it was huge now we're back
out there so my next show i got two
shows for top rope promotions coming up
um it's a great name tough road top
that's where i started it used to be
yankee pro wrestling um
way back in the day when i was a senior
in high school but um yeah we're in
brockton on the 20th uh i'll get that
information out of my social media and
then we're in fitchburg on the 22nd
and um then from there september 11th
i'm wrestling in the bethany town hall i
don't know if i'm wrestling i'm
basically like a producer so what is the
bethany town hall is it literally a town
hall they clear out the chairs so it's a
town hall with a basketball court it's
like a great place yeah like it gets and
they have die hard fans like we get the
same 300 it's our first one back since i
want to say
november for the first time i've been
back in the building since october or
november
of 2019. so like i'm really excited i'm
doing this new gimmick well it's not a
new gimmick it's the new look yeah i got
a new theme song it's like electro retro
and i got the new dance
you should have seen like
i watched some of your clips dude i love
it yeah you got like that you got like
you know it's an amalgam of a bunch of
different styles but it's you so i don't
want to say the styles because then
[ __ ] ass oh he's totally ripping over
which is what happens to comedians a lot
but like you have that thing man that
thing where it's like you annoy
and people love you all at the same time
which is a it's a very rare thing
um and it's one of those things where
you want to watch it just because you
want to read the comments right of the
people that take it seriously right i
mean i probably shouldn't even say take
it seriously because i'm kind of letting
the rabbit out of the hat but because i
love when people do that right you know
like i did recently i know it means you
got them well i made some stupid comment
about some news network and then for
like [ __ ] two weeks they just kept
picking [ __ ] out of my podcast it's like
guys i don't read
it
yeah like i am so [ __ ] not even
tapped into that that world right that a
comic did a joke about the vice
president and i didn't get it for half a
second i was like oh that's a joe biden
dementia oh okay yeah because they
didn't say it then they kind of brought
it around i was like oh that's right
they call them uh
what do they call them slow joe sleepy
joe sleepy yeah so i i i tapped out of
that world because uh that that's
nothing that makes me depressed news
news news and [ __ ] uh you know this
gym i was going to they'd have the
[ __ ] news on like silent and you're
on the treadmill and it's like this show
in california burning down covid numbers
going up plastic bottles in the ocean
i'm like what am i supposed to and of
course no solutions yep no
vendetta
it's crazy what's going on i mean the
media saw in my eyes i never saw that
movie that was funny
i'm like
missed that one yeah but it's just yeah
the times are i it's funny we talked and
you gave me some suggestions for content
i did a few videos about like what's
happened in the news right and i was
like dude i'm so depressed i was like i
can't like i was ripping on bill gates
and stuff like what the hell does he
know he's he had bad software or
whatever like what the hell does he know
about disease
he's like what the all right he'll take
his work or whatever you still still you
got to get your content and all that
stuff out there but i i 100 understand
not watching yeah uh the news which i
don't know some people might say is like
irresponsible or whatever but i've just
kind of gotten to the point of like all
right i'm just gonna yeah
you know how people that i can help out
and i'll i'll keep it at that but uh i
wish i was back here to check out those
uh those match you have because i tell
you this first time i spent like
significant time back in the boston area
for a while and uh
i'm kind of loving it yep i i think i
need to do a uh a mix
yeah yeah i really do like i was having
the best time coming up here to saugus
just all the memories i have yep and
like um just the food
well it's kind of fa well kowloon i
heard the uh the kids don't want to take
over the business so i don't know if
that's i don't know what's going on with
that but i was like
that thing i mean that's like a just a
legendary the [ __ ] comics that have
been up in that attic
over the years is uh is staggering not
to mention it's it's incredible food so
yep um
i don't know i think i'm gonna i was
you know talking to my wife about it and
she's really been liking being back here
granted it's the summer time yup you
know come back here during the winter
we'll be like yo [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] that i
[ __ ] left this 25 years ago this is
the perfect scraper right this is the
perfect time you go to florida in the
winter but you come up here yeah this
time all right well i am such a huge fan
of what you do and i'm really excited
for what you got going on in the future
and uh you know you got that producing
gig coming up you got the movie script
don't sleep on that either because this
is what the new thing is you got to have
like [ __ ] 20 irons right in the fire
and uh
i will give you advice if nobody like
finances that thing initially you can
always shoot a sizzle reel on your on
your iphone right and you just get
enough people into it right that's
that's the long way around yep so that's
all we do and the reason why i know
that's kind of what the [ __ ] i look like
no one's looking for a balding redhead
in hollywood i'll tell you that right
right now um anyways the one-man thrill
ride anything else you want to promote
yeah so you can visit me on my website
onemanthrillride.com that's where you
give me your money puppet we got tanks
yup we got teas yup we got sunnies yup
we got custom videos from yours truly on
instagram at one man thrill ride one on
instagram at the number one man throw
ride please give me a follow we got
content coming at a pretty ferocious
pace
one man thrill ride everybody this has
been the thursday afternoon just before
friday monday morning podcast enjoy the
music in the bonus episode from a
thursday last year or 10 years ago
however andrew does it have a great
weekend you [ __ ]
hey it's babel everyone you know when
you're traveling to a destination where
you don't know the language
it can be very challenging to accomplish
even the simplest of tasks where the
[ __ ] is the bathroom thankfully there's
babel the number one selling language
learning app
through babel's bite size lessons you'll
learn new language skills that you can
actually use in the real world
like learning things like hey get away
from me no
from greetings menus and directions to
gaining a deeper understanding of the
culture babel is a travel essential
babel's 15-minute lessons make it the
perfect way to learn a new language on
the go other language learning apps use
a.i for their lesson plans but babel
lessons were created by over 100
language experts the teaching method has
been scientifically proven to be
effective with babel you can choose from
14 different languages including spanish
french italian and german plus babel
speech recognition technology helps you
to improve your pronunciation and your
accent there are so many ways to learn
with babel in addition to lessons you
can access podcast games video stories
and even live classes start your new
language learning journey today with
babel right now when you put right now
when you purchase a three-month babel
subscription you'll get an additional
three months for free that's six months
uh for the price of three just go to
babel.com and use the promo code bird
that's babel b-a-b-b-e-l.com
code bur b-u-r-r babel language for life
oh look who it is everybody do do me
undies me undies some people think the
world is flat
be undies my undies some people had sex
with a cat
there's a lot of [ __ ] to people so why
would you listen
just get vaccinated that's the mission
yeah whatever do whatever the [ __ ] you
want
just make sure your balls are soft when
you sneeze on your [ __ ] grandparents
with a pair of me undies
you're working on the traffic problem
god bless you you know you know people
say imagine everyone in their underwear
to make you feel more comfortable as if
imagining a room full of strangers down
to their skivvies is what makes us comfy
well what if you work with a bunch of
attractive people now you're
uncomfortable and you're standing there
with the stinger
uh
[Music]
myani's believes comfort does not start
with imagining but instead starts with
the actual comfort that's why they make
the softest undies in fun prints to help
you feel comfortable at your course you
can feel ready to take on anything no
half naked room necessary
building your undies collection and
picking out uh which lucky pair gets to
meet your butt for the day has never
been so much fun choose prints and
corgis chicken nuggets your zodiac sign
goofy puns whatever the hell you want me
undies also relieves his uh collabs with
some pretty big names like the rolling
stones and space jam and new legacy
look at them working with the rolling
stones they've come so far myani's has a
great offer for my listeners for any
first-time purchasers you get 15 off and
free shipping myani's also has their
problem free philosophy if you're not
satisfied with any product for any
reason they'll refund it or exchange it
no caveats no questions no skid marks
either please um no get uh to get 50 off
your first order of free shipping and
100 satisfaction guarantee go to
meundies.com that's meundies.com
b-u-r-r for 15 off and free shipping 100
satisfaction guaranteed
and lastly but not leastly it's all
faithful stamps.com you know you've
heard me talk about stamps.com they've
been sponsoring the show for over nine
years now and if you haven't tried it
what the hell are you waiting for
stamps.com brings the same us postage
and ups shipping services right to your
computer they make it easy for small
businessmen to mail and ship without
needing to take a trip to the post
office stamps.com is a no-brainer saving
nearly 1 million small business owners
like you time and money they offer deals
you can't get anywhere else like up to
40 percent off usps and up to 66 off ups
shipping rates and with their switch and
save features you can quickly compare
carriers to find the best rates every
time stop wasting time going to the post
office and go to stamps.com instead
there's no risk and with my promo code
burr burr you get a special offer that
includes a four-week trial plus free
shipping and a digital scale no
long-term commitments or contracts just
go to stamps.com click on the microphone
at the top of the home page and type in
bur that's stamps.com promo code burr
[Music]
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast for
monday august 19th
2013 baby
um i am still in new orleans
my last two days here in new orleans i
want to thank everyone do you know what
it means
to miss new orleans that's where my baby
goes
she gets a po boy and pukes on a
sidewalk
down on bourbon street with all the
other [ __ ] horse
you like that that was a little uh
started off with something i don't know
some sort of basin street blues and i
ended up with clyde mccoy's
sugar blues
for all you out there who enjoy an
unbelievably white man playing a muted
trumpet
i highly recommend listening to clyde
mccoy's sugar blues
you know
if people other than white people were
running this country after that
recording came out white people would be
banned from ever playing the trumpet
again
i'm sure there's probably some clyde
mccoy fans out there and i'm sure i'm
offending you right now but i don't give
a [ __ ]
the man is no longer with us
and fortunately
play that horn anymore
those of you not gonna have time to look
it up
the muted trumpet song went something
like
[Music]
it's literally that bad
when i was six i thought it was good
ah [ __ ] you know i finally broke down i
went down to bourbon street
and uh
it was 20 to 5
on a saturday
20 to 5. what's funny in new orleans
is they have royal street
runs parallel to bourbon street it's one
block i guess north of it
i don't [ __ ] know
just night and day
you stay on royal street it's a bunch of
sane people some really good
unbelievable street performers out here
man
uh musicianship is crazy
but you know families
you know [ __ ] uh
all these antique stores
the gaslamp place the way the way they
make the gas lamps you know in case you
thought they made the gas lamp shed at
some other place they make it at the
gaslamp place they got it's just a bunch
of nice stuff
well you're like oh wow what a wonderful
town odd work
all this stuff to
do good clean fun on royal street you go
one block over over
and you're on bourbon street and it is
an absolute [ __ ] show i saw a
well she didn't take care of herself so
she could have been anywhere from 26 to
about 59.
[Laughter]
she had some hard miles people all right
she was running with uh she was down a
couple quarts oil for at least two
decades if you know what i mean
you might need to uh you know get a
little valve job done on your hoo-ha
there lady
um
anyways
she's uh i'm sitting drinking
and uh i'm in this bar there's nobody
else in it and everybody in the bar is
dressed like they're like coach from
cheers
in the band you know and they're playing
i don't know what the [ __ ] they were
playing
sort of jazzy sort of new orleans
sounded [ __ ]
and so i'm sitting there and i'm just
you know it's open view i'm just
watching people going down the street i
took some video of it
all right there was this white dude
with great hair you know
[ __ ] dirty as hell full head of
[ __ ] this guy could run for office
with the head of hair that he had but
instead he decided to mop the gutters
with it for the last [ __ ]
i don't know since the 70s and he was
out skipping around freaking people out
he you know what's funny that guy had
been a drunk for so long when he would
sit down when anybody would approach him
he would immediately put his hands up
like hey i'm not [ __ ] doing anything
why are you hassling me he's just so
used to being hassled man that when
somebody comes up to him
or he's so used to people coming up to
him telling him that he needs to to tone
down his behavior that the second and
anybody got in his peripheral he
immediately put his hands up hey man you
know i'm just sitting here man
um he had his little bottle of booze
then there was this hilarious black dude
directing traffic
making most people laugh and driving
control freaks out of their [ __ ]
minds so that was fun
this is all at like 20 to five in the
afternoon
sun had even started to set and then
across the street this woman i don't 58
59 maybe early 60s
she's with her guy and this other couple
and she starts
getting all [ __ ] loopy or whatever
and she just
uh
she blew ciao
to bring back the old way we used to say
puked back in the day she blew chow all
over the [ __ ] sidewalk
and this is the funny thing all she did
when she threw up was she just like
it was like somebody said can you see
your toes and she was like you know i
don't think i've
i've tried to see my toes in a long time
she just looked just she just looked
straight down and just [ __ ] yacked
it kind of ricocheted off her belly and
then hit the sidewalk so
she was near the land mind but was was
fine
as long as she took a step back or if
she went right or she went left and she
just [ __ ]
she went straight
she took one step and did a benny hill
[ __ ] slip
not really she did like she sort of
collapsed like bambi
and just landed in in her own [ __ ]
puke
um and her friends sort of were
comforting her letting her sit in her
own pew it was [ __ ] unreal i mean
while the other guy is skipping around
with his bottle of bulls hey man leave
me alone
and uh so i think i put him in like a
ufc chokehold which i don't even know if
he knew the guy he just put him into it
in a joking way and the drunk dude with
the great hair immediately just played
along and was sticking his tongue out
and i don't know what the [ __ ] was going
on and then the black guy was still
directed traffic and i'm looking at my
watch he's [ __ ] 25.
on a saturday
and and the thing is the people who are
them
who are an absolute [ __ ] mess they
should be antiquing the age that they
were
and uh all those stores that are really
nice on royal street all of them were
closing up that's how i ended up in a
bar i was like why are you guys all
closing up and they're like ah you know
we close up around five
gets a little crazy one block oh it
turns into such a [ __ ] show that they
just they uh
they just closed down
um
or whatever so
anyways i've i've had despite that crazy
story i've had i've had a great time
down here and i've kind of becoming a
saints fan i got to get out of here soon
because i'm kind of becoming a uh a
saints fan i got all into the
sentimental
part of it of their their longtime
announcer
of course i don't have his name in front
of me here i'm gonna i don't want to
butcher this
he did his last show
um his last show
is he doing stand-up bill no he did his
last
uh broadcast saints let me look this up
here so i get this right and [ __ ] all
you guys down here in new orleans giving
me [ __ ] right now i'm not from here
retires bang
here we go
long time saints announcer retires can i
get a name jerry roaming
and uh you gotta listen to some clips of
him on uh
on youtube he's another one of those
classic throwback guys total homer it's
awesome
and i hope he doesn't oh he's getting
replaced by his son so he'll be a homer
too i just hate when they go from a
homer to just some guy where you don't
know where they're from
and you just get someone you know you
know what the [ __ ] i'm trying to say
anyways this is the monday morning
podcast everybody
uh
oh people have been asking me you know i
want to send emails in man
where do i send it bill at the
mmpodcast.com that's where you send them
in if you have any [ __ ] questions
this that and the other and all that
[ __ ]
so um
yeah this i got two more days
two more days on this movie that i'm
doing down here i know i've been [ __ ]
around saying that i'm doing an episode
of glee obviously you guys don't know
that for those who didn't look it up i'm
doing a movie down here called black and
white
with uh kevin costner
and octavia spencer
um
and it's been an unbelievable time
unbelievable shooting that whole time
it's been amazing so uh i have this
weird sort of i'm excited to get the
[ __ ] out of here
and um um
also gonna be a little sad been here for
a while oh and also of course directed
by mike binder
um
they all got great boston names
costner spencer
binder
um so that i don't know when it's going
to come out probably going to come out
next year so uh i don't know why i'm
[ __ ] hyping a movie that we haven't
even finished shooting yet
but i guess that's what you have to do
nowadays because there's 9 000 channels
so look out for it i think it's gonna be
a great one
there we go and on to the stories for
this week
a romanian doctor
um did you guys see this story this is
one of these stories i just don't
believe is true
even though i retweeted it i refuse to
believe that this is [ __ ] true
it says stressed out doctor cuts off
man's elf patient's penis
all right
i don't know how to say the guy's name
nom
see omu 58
what is with the 58 year olds this week
they're not puking on bourbon street
they're cutting off somebody's dick
really does this have to do with the
size of the moon
in the sky
the moon is remember they always [ __ ]
talk about how that affects your goddamn
mood
the moon does it
and exactly how does that work
i would love to just see a table full of
scientists listen to this laughing their
asses off right now
wiping tears from their eyes unto their
[ __ ] i'm smart white coats
um anyways uh anyways now um
58 was operating
on a man to correct a testicular mouth
malformation
you see that this is a vanity thing
his balls were working fine he just
didn't like how one of them looked
you know kind of like when a woman has
one wonky titty
like once once
focused and the others the backup
quarterback checking out the chicks in
the front row you know
so evidently he had the same problem
except it was his balls
so anyways
he lost his temper trying to fix this
guy's balls
so he grabs a scalpel and he sliced off
the guy's dick
i love this word here in front of an
amazed nursing staff not horrified
not nauseated amazed
how did he do that
you know he would have thought that one
of us would try to stop him but by the
time i realized what he was doing he
already did it
god
do you think we'll ever be that good
um and it may evidently that's an
amazing thing for a nurse to see in
romania
they were amazed
um and then not to mention this after he
cuts the dick off
he then cuts it into three pieces for
those of you mathematicians out there
that's two cuts
height height
i wonder if he just stabbed the scalpel
in there into the table and then that
was it
all right and then he stormed out of the
operating theater
at the panduri urology hospital in
bucharest
that's the capital ii of romania so
there's no excuse for this behavior this
guy should be the best of the best
he's working in the capitol i can see if
he was out in the sticks
you know out in worcester
um
what the [ __ ] was going through this
guy's head did he not have the right
equipment did he keep getting the
malformed ball into shape and then it
kept on malforming and you know
like when your [ __ ] computer keeps
crashing
that's basically what this guy did like
you ever get mad at your cell phone and
you just [ __ ] throw it
he did the medical version of that and
evidently that involves cutting off a
dick
um
so this it gets even weirder
a romanian court has ordered
professor
siomo whatever his name to pay a hundred
grand damages and twenty
and twenty thousand dollars cost to the
victim
what are his costs
did you still charge him for the
operation well you know we did kind of
shape up one of your balls
tell you what that was going to be 40
grand but we'll take 50 percent off
and all the gauze unique
um and this guy was a 36 year old
builder 36 year old
the trauma again this is what the guys
now this is
his underwhelming statement the trauma
has left a deep mark both physically and
psychologically it's hard for a man who
wants to have sex sex yet lacks the
organ my wife is the best thing i have
that's just fun it's the worst [ __ ]
thing there's no way this is true
how do you how do you know this [ __ ] is
true
even if you see it on i saw it on the
news so what
so what how do you how do you know what
happened
let me look at this there's another one
this is the one up in uh newfoundland
right
40 pythons found in canada motel
10 days after two boys were killed by an
escaped snake
did you see that story like how do you
how do you [ __ ] know that that
happened
unless you were there
other than that i'm just sitting there
and i'm listening to some woman talking
and then they got a picture of a snake
over her [ __ ] shoulder and then they
cut to somebody standing out in front of
the house it's true jennifer it's true
tragedy did strike today in this great
house
if you could see that window here as
well versus snake was and somehow
i don't know how it went up the stairs i
mean maybe they had those round ones you
know the spiral staircase and it went up
the stripper pole that's in the middle i
have no idea but
anyway somehow it managed to get up to
the second floor at eight not one but
two
they basically said that that was very
abnormal
for a snake for snake lovers
is about two canadian brothers
apparently squeezed to death
by a 15 foot african python
uh they were typical children who
enjoyed life to the maximum yeah i mean
they're six and four
what's one of them looking through a
[ __ ] telescope already i guess it
could be advanced learning
everybody's typical at six and four
did i miss my calling i maybe i'm this
is like
this is what i should i should have
written news articles
this is how [ __ ] dumb you can be
the nursing staff was hey what's that
word
just amazed amazed right amazed yeah
that sounds good what are you getting
for lunch
um
and spent the last days
alive playing with animals on a farm a
relative said tuesday the boys were a
sleepover in an apartment above a pet
store when the snakes struck
canadian police said it slithered
oh did it it didn't walk into the room
it sliggered slithered through the top
of its
its floor to ceiling cage
jesus christ out of a hole connected to
a ventilation system and dropped from
the living room ceiling when a pipe
broke
autopsies oh my god it's terrible so
anyways this guy says that this was not
um
said it was abnormal
for a snake to go on a on a killing
spree
you know which i i believe that
right they just kind of they just take
what they need they only eat just enough
if you look when's the last time you saw
a fat snake i mean they're all muscle
right
so this one i don't know what this
[ __ ] thing
deal was
i think it was like thanksgiving it just
[ __ ] kept going but am i really
talking about a snake that killed two
[ __ ] little boys i'm sorry
i'm sorry
all right what am i gonna do make fun of
the po boys in the goddamn [ __ ]
paddle boat out there again
oh that [ __ ] paddle boat's driving me
nuts
unfortunately it's out to sea
can you be out to sea on a river what is
an eddie does anybody know what is
difference between a sea and an ocean
that's the kind of thing like if if
you're not a captain
or you you're not in the navy
i mean i bet half the people in the
[ __ ] navy couldn't tell you the
difference between an eddie a sea
a gulf
everything to me is the ocean like the
gulf of mexico to me that's the [ __ ]
ocean
don't be talking to me how oh it's
surrounded on three sides yeah and what
[ __ ] 9 000 miles in each direction
i'm in the middle of the [ __ ] ocean
right
the only reason why the great lakes
aren't oceans to me is because they're
not salty
i stick my face in them i don't go
i don't do that [ __ ]
and you know that one that they have out
there in california the sultan sea
that's all salty that's the [ __ ]
ocean
it's not a lake
it's not a sea that is the [ __ ] ocean
it got left above it got left behind
like willem dafoe and um
in platoon
you know i just found out all that out
that thought that all that desert out
there that used to be the bottom of an
ocean i had no idea so wouldn't that
mean
no that wouldn't mean that i was gonna
say that this was [ __ ] dinosaurs down
there
there's some sort of oil
do they ever drill in the desert for
foil
dude what the [ __ ] you think your middle
east is
now go [ __ ] yourself
you ever been there you don't even know
what it looks like you just see it on
the news like i do
what is the middle east to you
what is it huh our planes flying in
there people throwing rocks at them
that's your geography before you get on
your [ __ ] high horse dude i'm sorry
i'm in this mood i am bored shitless out
here i i i i'm done
i got two more days i want to bang this
[ __ ] out and i want to get on the first
[ __ ] one smoking and get the [ __ ] out
of here i've had it i need to go home i
need to be with my stuff
all right i miss my stuff
you know i really miss the most i miss
my pajamas
i haven't seen my pajamas in a month
how long do you have pajamas before you
lose the top you don't even know where
the [ __ ] it is you only wear the bottoms
right
just walking around scratching your
balls
making that face when you look into the
kit into the refrigerator and there's
just nothing there that looks edible
i mean everything's work
um anyways let's do let's do a little uh
little advertising for the week here um
dollar shave club everybody
there are so many things in the world
that irritate me
raccoon hands
i don't like the they i don't like the
raccoon hats
they creep me out the word expedite i
don't like that word
i didn't think it is a word
all right if it is a word it became a
word from stewardesses saying it because
the only [ __ ] people i've ever heard
say it
and uh what else oh people will hold
their nose before jumping into a pool
you know
can you just breathe out your nose can't
you just do that
how old are you right
um anyways with all the so many things
in the world that can irritate you why
would you let your razors add to it that
doesn't make any sense what i'm trying
to say is stop milking your razor blade
for the entire month
you know digging up your face
i know the brand name razors you're used
to paying outrageous prices and
exhausting those razors until they start
to look like a rusty coat soda can i
realize this well it's time to let that
go it's time to move on dollar shave
club delivers amazing quality blades to
your door for just a few bucks a month
you never have to think about it again
they send a pack every month just for a
few bucks you can change your blades
every week trust me your face will love
you for it that's true i use it and you
should too join dollar shave club shave
time shave money you get it go to
dollarshaveclub.com that's
dollarshaveclub.com
or click on the dollar shave banner
dollar shave club banner sorry on the
bottom of the podcast page at
billberry.com all right hulu plus
everyone
i'm sure you've tried hulu.com if you
hadn't if you haven't done that i'm sure
that's why your friends aren't talking
to you anymore
all right but if you have been to
hulu.com i want to tell you about hulu
plus
hulu plus lets you watch thousands of
hit shows anytime anywhere stream it on
your tv or go with it or you can put it
on your smartphone or your tablet
why stand in a line or ride a train and
just stare at your feet before puking
and then slipping in it you could be
watching your favorite shows on hulu
plus hulu plus is a great way to binge
watch your favorite shows hula plus has
tons of episodes from great comedies
like snl
community modern family south park
family guy and thousands of other shows
hulu plus is only 7.99 a month everybody
that's 7.99 for all the shows and movies
you can watch catch up on current shows
binge on old favorite or catch just
catch a great movie
whatever you want to do you can do it
all on hulu plus people right now you
can try hulu plus for a couple weeks
free on me when you go to the podcast
page at billboard.com and click on the
hulu plus banner i'll go to huluplus.com
bill please make sure you use
huluplus.com bill so you can get an
extended free trial and so they know
that we sent you all right helps me keep
the lights on here and gives you a
better deal one more time for extended
free trial huluplus.com
um hey we only got one more i might as
well knock it out e-voice
everybody if you're an entrepreneur and
a custom customer
let me try that again billboard boys
take two
boop
e-voice if you're an entrepreneur
i'm sorry guys i'm sorry i'm sorry i
went out last night
billboard reads you always take three
e-voice
if you were an entrepreneur and a
customer calls do you want to seem like
you're in a high-rise window view fancy
pants office or do you want them to know
you're sitting in your underwear
with e-voice you can create the
appearance of an entire building sales
customer support tech support you name
it
give your customers the royal treatment
with e-voice e-voice will forward your
business calls to your home mobile or
any number you choose
wherever you are e-voice will find you
don't have time to take a call it's
routed to your voicemail and you can
read it at your convenience as an email
evoice not only gives you an edge over
competitors it takes away the edge the
big companies have over you right now
and now you can try evois for free for
30 days go to evoice.com and use the
promo code bill that's evoice.com promo
code bill or just go to the podcast
page at billboard.com and click on the
for email ah the e-voice banner
sorry all right that's the advertising
for this week that's always a great way
to end advertising sorry
i apologize i'm not qualified for the
job
um
all right
what else did i want to talk about this
week uh have you guys been checking out
what's going on over there in egypt man
that's just a goddamn tragedy over there
those people you know what uh democracy
is too it's too new over there
you elected a guy turns out you elected
the wrong guy you didn't like him you
just gotta wait for the next election
and then you vote the bum out
you know you don't [ __ ] just demand
the guy leaves
you do that here comes the army
right you're sitting there with [ __ ]
rocks in a dream i don't know it doesn't
work out too good
um
all right
this is a [ __ ] disjointed podcast
i've ever heard one i swear to god
sometimes i really wonder why you guys
continue to listen
oh bill stop [ __ ] me oh you know bill
why why why what do you mean like that
guy who threatens to kill himself and
never does just so you can hear so much
people love him no no why you listen to
that oh bill don't stop podcasting we
love your podcasting your red [ __ ]
all right follow up
on salads let's get into the uh the
emails for the week
oh you know what i didn't finish last
week was i started to say i was actually
rooting for a-rod and people mentioned
that i i forgot to say why
um
i don't know why there was something
about everybody bowing them that just
made me uh just
just the level with which people were
booing the guy
you know and i'm a complete look this is
how i look at it
i can't judge the dude
the only way you could boom like that as
if you lived a perfect life
all right
all that money on the [ __ ] table
come on complete piece of [ __ ] like me
you think i'm not gonna [ __ ] do some
roids
to hang in the game do you think if they
made a steroid that allowed you to read
advertising smoothly that i wouldn't be
on the juice right now
just so i could stay in the podcasting
league for another couple years or two
for the kids i don't have to feed
um
there's
i you know what it is i don't like how
people
they uh
i don't think it's fair that they look
at like entertainers and athletes the
way they do and start saying this is
what's wrong with this country
they start going down like that and then
they just [ __ ] let bankers go
if they if they gave just as much [ __ ]
more [ __ ] to bankers and then they came
on athletes and entertainment is like
that i'd be like that makes sense that
makes sense to me you know what i'm
going to do i'm going to i'm going to
[ __ ] start my own trading cards
rather than tops like baseball or
football cards i'm going to start mine
and it's going to be banker cards so
everybody knows what they look like and
their [ __ ] stats will be on the back
all the horrific [ __ ] that they did
and i don't know maybe they'd get booed
when they're on the way to their lobster
[ __ ] encrusted lunch wouldn't that be
nice every once in a while so there you
have it for some stupid reason i'm
rooting for a-rod i wanted to hit him a
bunch of [ __ ] home runs
and uh i don't know what after that
just because everybody if only a few
people boot him i'd still be against
them but the fact that everybody was
just [ __ ] trash a couple people had
sides
but uh some [ __ ] said the other day you
know what's good all these pds really
puts that pete rose thing into
perspective but
it now no it doesn't
no it doesn't gambling is the worst
[ __ ] thing you can do it's worse than
peds it's worse than an individual
cheating
all right you're talking about when you
start gambling you're talking about
throwing the game
then it becomes wrestling
right and i'm not saying that on a
certain level that you're up in the ante
with the peds you definitely are but
gambling is the worst the outcome of the
game
cannot be decided before the [ __ ]
game starts you can't have people doing
that [ __ ] all right you want to take
some go-go juice and maybe change the
outcome
i think that's half as bad why is my
voice you know when i was in a bar last
night screaming over music
um it's not as bad and for everybody
who's going to send me a [ __ ] email
about it at bill at the mmpodcast.com
i'm telling you right now i'm closed off
to your opinions you can try and sway me
but i don't want to [ __ ] hear it
gambling on baseball it's the worst
thing you can do that's why they have it
over every everything when you walk down
the tunnel that's what they have
oh by the way don't go out there and
throw the game this isn't wrestling all
right put on your aqua velva go out
there and try
all right sorry follow up on salads
people
bill i make salads for a living while
eating vegetables from your grocery
store is better than nothing oh jesus
christ he gonna talk about pesticides
and then kill me
he goes you should urge your listeners
to go to independent farm stands i'm
from new england and they're everywhere
try smelling a peach that's from a farm
versus one from the grocery store this
guy's 100 right
here you should go to a farmer's market
the one from the grocery store won't
smell at all it's because they picked it
too soon and lacks up to 75 percent of
the nutrients yeah that's why tomatoes
taste like [ __ ]
and people when they make a caprici
salad they'll [ __ ] put the balsamic
vinaigrette on it to try to or you make
a uh
when you make your pizza sauce they
always in and throw in you know
whatever [ __ ]
30 cup of sugar depending on how much
you [ __ ] use it but that that's the
natural sweetness that isn't in the
tomato because from what i've
kind of read on a website maybe
like uh hey maybe you can handle this
fuckhead.com i think i went to that and
they were talking about tomatoes
or anyways once once you basically
the the fruit of the vegetable gets all
its
all its nutrients from the vine or the
branch the tree whatever the [ __ ] it's
hanging from right so once you yank that
off it's over
okay
uh
i can't use that reference i wasn't
talking about taking a baby out of a
womb too early that's disgusting because
we're talking about eating something
all right
ah jesus christ bill
um anyways yeah if you go down to your
farmer's market it's much better that's
what he's trying to say
but
i've actually seen the thing where are
starting to infiltrate the farmers
markets because those [ __ ] can just not
make enough money
but anyways thank you for the follow-up
i would have liked if you gave me a
recipe
for a couple of salads
if you make salads for a living that
would be great help help the listeners
out give us a little variety
give give i want three here one
to ease somebody in to the fact that
they're eating a salad if they went from
eating a goat's head every goddamn day
and then the second one um i don't know
make it down a medium-sized one and then
the last one is uh if you just want to
[ __ ] your brains out and have energy of
superman
all right how about how about three
salads like that that's my request sir
thank you send it to the to bill at the
mmpodcast.com all right all right here
we go follow up from a lady
hey billy i'm a lady
just want to uh offer a piece of advice
referring to the guy on your last
podcast who called in about his
ex-girlfriend texting him after they had
broken up
um
she says i've actually been one of those
country girls you were talking about and
have broken up with guys in the past my
advice to guys listening out there is
the absolute best thing you could do
when an ex calls or texts you
is to remain completely bored sounding
on the phone
oh completely board signing on the phone
never text or call them back sound as
distant and un and as uninterested as
possible
when talking to them guaranteed the ex
will never co ever call again because
it's humiliating
that was my experience anyways
your advice was correct that you need to
just cut the cancer out delete from cell
phone unfriend etc etc hope you read
this out loud okay sometimes it helps to
put a finger under each word when
reading
she said just being cheeky
um
god i hate that [ __ ] word
are you being cheeky
all right so there's great advice
from a lady there you go she says just
sound completely as completely bored and
and uninterested as possible it's
humiliating to them
yeah because you really you know what
you're doing you're pouring water on
their lightsaber basically
does that make any sense well lightsaber
looks more like a dick what am i trying
to say was there anything that's
somebody used as a jedi that kind of
looked like a [ __ ] pot
that lit up that you could pour water on
was that electricity that's what i was
thinking you pour water and what would
that do would probably zap your hand if
you had a metal [ __ ] my references
are [ __ ] terrible this week
you're shutting off their uh i don't
know you're turning off their [ __ ]
the gas lamp above their [ __ ] you're
just putting it out
um the best thing to do is you just
[ __ ] get away from them or they're
going to make your life a living health
that's what they do
they don't duke it out
except for those broads on the ufc
jab to the to the tit jab to the tit
uppercut to the [ __ ] areola
these body blows up brutal
kick to the womb
oh
right in the vajayjay she's got a
[ __ ] hanger for the standing eight
count
all right was he a virgin dear billy
dear bill
first of all i'd like to say i'm a huge
fan from your hometown of uh wakaluka
makaduka you are a comedian you are my
comedian crush
i absolutely love you well you've
obviously never met me believe me
i'm a piece of [ __ ] and i'm difficult to
live with so
why don't you set your standards a
little higher
says now to the problem i was celibate
for almost two years i grew tired of it
and decided to sleep with the guy
i've liked for a little
i've liked for a little but i didn't
know him too well let me start by saying
honestly this isn't something i do ever
but i needed to get laid
it was a [ __ ] thing to do no it wasn't
it wasn't
all right
you [ __ ] have that urge whatever you
want how you did it yeah what the [ __ ]
you gonna do um
but oh well
i was good long i was good for long
enough anyways he's a little socially
awkward and quiet which i initially
thought was cute but found out there's a
lot more awkwardness in him
i don't know the date itself was awkward
but i was horny and he's a nice guy so i
wanted to get
so i wanted to get it in
all right this person's not [ __ ]
around here
um
he started by nestling his head in my
breast and rubbing his nose on them
in between and all around
he did this also when i got on top of
him but when he did it he he did
something extremely strange he squeezed
my breast very rapidly
almost as if to honk them
i laughed at first because i thought he
was playing but he kept doing that and
then he did the same thing to my ass
multiple times
oh my god
she says i'm
well in doubt in both of those areas so
i understand him playing with them but
something was strange about it
this is really [ __ ] weirding me out i
don't know why
then beat you down
was he doing it like at the same time or
was he like alternating with each hand
he should have been doing that while
winking either eye you know
just completely freaking you on
occasionally sticking his tongue out
you go into some sort of [ __ ]
epileptic seizure
anyway she said when he touched me
anywhere else he would only use the palm
of his hand
at one point we were laying next to each
other on the bed maybe he just doesn't
know what he's doing and i guess he
remembered i said i like my hair pulled
so he randomly grabbed a fistful of my
hair and yanked it this sounds like
somebody who can't dance trying to dance
to something up tempo this is [ __ ]
horrific
i feel horrible for this guy
like this is like this is such a bad
performance
this is like a first round draft pick
bust like three games in you're like oh
my god what did we just throw a million
dollars at this is over
give this guy a clipboard
um anyways
she said we were not even having sex yet
and and it wasn't like he guided my head
to his lap or anything
what
when we finally did have sex it lasted
less than a minute and i'm not
exaggerating when he told me he was
about to finish i told him
to get on top so he could have more
control
but he put all of his body weight on me
and was done in half a stroke
oh my god
all in one all right
he [ __ ] threw the hail mary
again i'm not exaggerating he went down
on me to compensate and i'll spare you
further details but he knew nothing
about what he was doing yeah i kind of
gathered that
i was nice throughout this
because i never thought
because i never would want to give
anyone a complex well you [ __ ] said
where you live
that's why i feel bad about this i'm
gonna have to uh have that bleeped out
i'm gonna bleep that out i don't wanna
[ __ ] blow up anybody's body 38
minutes in all right all right all right
39 minutes in
um i'll spare you the further details
but he knew nothing about what he's
doing i was nice throughout this because
i never want to give anyone a complex
but dude what the [ __ ] did i just [ __ ]
an autistic man or a virgin he's 26 and
he's a sweet guy i almost want to teach
him
but i don't want to insult him any
advice
all right well first things first do you
like the guy
do you even like the guy
before you get involved in this the
money pit here as far as fixer-up houses
goes
um
i don't know from the i don't know if
you were just trying to be funny but
from the way you described this
you know that there has to be a jumping
off point ah who knows
who knows maybe maybe i don't know i
don't [ __ ] know 26 years old
i don't know and he's [ __ ] grabbing
your ass like if you see somebody who
knows how to make an omelette really
quick and can [ __ ] open them up eggs
with one hand it's like he's doing that
with your [ __ ] titties and your ass
it's just weird
but you see all right i'm gonna go with
you like him because what can you do uh
jesus christ where to start
you didn't even mention him kissing you
you know i i don't know i think this
guy's [ __ ] weird
the [ __ ] was with the nose all around
your titties
i don't know what to tell you i i got to
give you advice here because this is the
advice part
i almost want to teach him i don't want
to insult him any advice
how the [ __ ] do you go about this it's
just such a [ __ ] you know usually
when you give somebody advice you know
who's sensitive what you do is you
complement the things that they did well
first and then you ease into uh they
this could maybe use a little work here
not saying you're bad because you did
this well just saying this over here
maybe
is there did he do anything well
[Laughter]
how was he when he pulled his pants back
up was that pretty smooth
uh you know
he gets ball stuck in the zipper was he
able to not do that maybe he could start
with that
um
ah jesus isn't this so this is why women
are so amazing the fact that she's
actually willing to work with this
she's going to try to make this work
i don't i don't know
i i guess i would try and figure out
something that he did well and i would
compliment that and then i would just
start chipping away at the mountain
i wouldn't try to bring the whole
mountain down in one day
but uh
you know just know you you get a long
[ __ ] road ahead of you
jesus christ you took two years off from
sex and now you know
it sounds like you were having sex with
like the first robot ever
and there was somebody like
controlling them
you know and they had an inability to to
they have robot hands caress
so when you know comments correct
caressing
right
he was needing dough
oh jesus
hey good luck with that
i'm sorry i got to start sending dvds to
people who i just can't [ __ ] come up
with anything i got i got nothing all
right nicknames
bill what is the best way to respond to
a nickname that you hate
i recently got one due to a simple rhyme
with my name
uh i didn't do anything stupid or [ __ ]
to earn it it was funny at first but
after a few months i find myself getting
annoyed and angry
when called by my f by this name most
people have moved on and stopped calling
me that however two or three people
still greet me with it every chance they
get how do i shed this name without
looking like a douche and potentially
making things worse all right first of
all you don't let on how much it bugs
you and then what you do is you come
back giving them the [ __ ] howitzer
all right you got to come back
with the anti-aircraft you got to look
you got to come up with nicknames for
these [ __ ] people
just start with one guy don't do all
three at once because they'll know what
you're up to just pick one guy
all right we're gonna slowly whack these
guys one one by one get this dude that
guy then you get mo green through his
[ __ ] glasses and we're done
um
they got a big nose
something physically [ __ ] up about
their face
they got man tits
they'll get it real quick they're
calling you something hey what's up
there flabby tits or man tits or just
something something about them that you
know that they hate about themselves
hopefully something that's unfixable
you know unless they went under the
knife and god knows what
don't do it in romania right that's what
i would do but the first thing you do it
do not let on that it bugs you so when
they call you whatever they call you
just sort of laugh
big smile and then you just [ __ ] hit
him with you give me all right there
fred all right that'll shut him up
hopefully
that's what i would do
or you just quit your job
if all else fails
you get the [ __ ] out of there change
your name
uh but the worst thing you want to do is
go stop calling me that
that then that just it's [ __ ] it's
over
it's over
um then you have live action twitter in
your [ __ ] life
getting trashed 24 7
live action facebook or whatever all
right embarrassing
um
bill i can't spell for [ __ ]
um so let so let it go before you start
hitching
uh you know what go [ __ ] yourself i
gotta sit here and i gotta undo all of
this
embarrassing he spells that wrong
embarra embarrassing he spelled e
embarrassing he spelled it
e-m-b-a-r-s-s-i-n-g
see people i'm not the only one dumb i'm
just gonna read this how he wrote it i
can't spell for [ __ ]
so let so let it go before you start
hitching
funny story wanted to share it with
capital y a
i promise this is true an older man i
know
had gotten a vasectomy he smelt it right
with it with this new age laser laser
treatment they do it's an in and out
kind of treatment now
was asked to come back a week or two
later to make sure everything held up
the way it was supposed to when he got
there he told the lady behind the desk
why
why he was there and she handed him a
cup and told him they needed a sample
and pointed to the bathroom oh no did
she mean jizz or
whiz
waiting room which was filled with
people fyi he went in and 15 minutes
later came out with a cup of mango and
proceeded to walk past the people and
placed the cup under her desk she slowly
looked up at him and told him in front
of everyone
that she only needed a urine test
wow god
oh my god i i really hope that's true
how do you [ __ ] well she only gave
him a cup
the [ __ ] is he supposed to do they hand
you a cup that means that means to rub
one out right
the hands
they give you that plastic bottle that
means you're supposed to pee in it
ah
they do that [ __ ] all the time
at doctor's offices
like they just forget
because they're there and it doesn't
mean [ __ ] and they will just yell out
you know
anything
you just come walking in hey dr
so-and-so hey how are you did it clear
up
if you look at the one clear up
and they immediately think he's got
something on his balls man
is that contagious
um
that's [ __ ] hilarious
damn it that's [ __ ] embarrassing
i wonder what kind of a bathroom it was
did it have multiple toilets people
coming in there pissing and he's over
there
they probably make a noise because the
doctor because he feels the doctor said
to do it that it's like somehow okay oh
by the way
this is sort of a hacky [ __ ] joke and i
don't want to do it on stage but i'm
sick of people complaining
about people blowing out the bathroom
oh my god this guy came when he [ __ ]
blew out the bathroom oh maybe next time
he should take a [ __ ] in the kitchen
you know that's what that's what it's
for
it's a it's designed so you can sit down
and take a [ __ ]
you want him to go outside in the yard
it's like being mad bacon smells like
bacon
jesus what the [ __ ] did you eat i don't
know something healthy and then it
stayed in me for a couple of [ __ ]
days it went through nine miles of
intestinal you know
clinging on other [ __ ] that what did
your [ __ ] smell like
i never understood them
like when i go into a bathroom and
somebody blew it out i [ __ ] makes me
laugh
it's just the face you're making trying
not to smell it's [ __ ] hilarious
that's it with that and when people get
mad that babies cry on planes when
babies start crying on planes i just
start laughing
because i just feel like they're
expressing everything that i'm feeling
but i'm not socially allowed
i would love to just start crying
i don't want to be on another [ __ ]
plane
the second they say expedite the
boarding process i just want to start
[ __ ] crying
anyways x won't move out oh jesus christ
here's a [ __ ] situation
hey bill huge fan of yours love that
love the monday morning podcast i will
keep this short as i know you don't like
to read
i like to read i'm just not good at it
i'm like someone who likes to play drums
but stinks at it um i recently bought a
house and asked my girlfriend of three
years to move in with me we have been
living together for about six months and
then we broke up
she was the worst all my friends and
family did not like her and she wouldn't
let me hang out with friends no no no
no let's let's put that
in proper perspective it's not that she
wouldn't let you hang out with friends
she asked you not to and you agreed to
it all right you have you have the power
sir anyways she wouldn't let me hang out
with my friends or watch any games with
friends ever capital all in caps i tried
to get her to hang out with
with her friends but she was so insecure
she never trusted me even after three
years of loyalty anyways we broke up
about three weeks ago no one cheated
lied or stole from one another it was
just time to move on however she keeps
saying she's going to move out but
doesn't
um
i don't want to throw her out on the
street but what do i do but but i do
want her out
as it's just not healthy for me to keep
living with her also she refuses to pay
any bills or help with the mortgage
what's a fair amount of time to give her
before i just go legal on her
well
hindsight's 20 20 you should have told
her from day one when she had to be out
by
um
the fact that she's not paying any bills
or anything like that i mean it's just
like
i would just hit her with a little
two-pronged
attack here i would just go listen
um we broke up three
uh how would you dip into this [ __ ]
oh gives a [ __ ] just i was gonna say be
like hey how's the
apartment hunted coming i would just go
right at it i would just say listen uh
it's been three weeks and i really don't
think it's healthy for us to be around
each other
um
when do you think you're going to be out
of here by and let her answer amanda and
then just say listen i will i need you
to be out by this date because i have to
get somebody else in here to help me
with the mortgage all right you're not
paying any bills or helping with the
mortgage so this isn't fair to me
so you need to be out of here
and her name isn't on the mortgage so
worst case scenario
one day she goes to work you call in
sick
pack up all this [ __ ]
and [ __ ]
put it out on the front lawn you're out
and what she's gonna say what you gonna
do call the [ __ ] cops
you don't have to go legal on her get
the [ __ ] out of here this is my house we
broke up get out
out
you
out get
out
get up um i don't actually i don't know
if she has any
anything legal i have no idea i don't
[ __ ] know but that's what i would do
i would give her a definitive date you
need to be out by this time
and uh
i don't know
what else i don't want else to do my my
ah there's it's stupid we get it we're
on the mississippi with the [ __ ] horn
i get it
um
just make up some [ __ ] too i need you
out by the 15th of next month uh you
know my uncle uh
my second uncle lives in tennessee he's
got tuberculosis he's moving in
and uh he's bringing that machine with
them so
you got to get the [ __ ] out of here all
right that's the podcast for this week
everybody i know it was kind of a short
one oh jesus 52 minutes i can't do that
to you
well i could technically i could if i
wanted to if i wanted to be a dick about
it
[Music]
um i just gotta i got
a bunch of scenes tomorrow and i gotta
learn all my [ __ ] lines that's why
i'm doing this thing early hey you gotta
you gotta admit when i'm shooting
something the [ __ ] podcast comes out
on time
this is gonna be three weeks in a row
with this thing being out
like sunday night in most areas
so um how about a little props
you know
how about for once you don't give me
[ __ ] you actually give me a little bit
of uh oh [ __ ] i got to be somewhere in
40 minutes god damn it all right this is
an extra short one i'm i apologize i'll
try and make it up with the longer one
over the last couple weeks so they they
have been long um all right i got to get
moving here [ __ ] christ
um all right that's the podcast for this
week now that the show's over don't
forget to sign up for your free trial of
hulu plus hulu plus lets you binge on
thousands of hit shows anytime anywhere
on your tv pc smartphone or tablet
support this podcast also and get an
extended free trial of hulu plus when
you go to the podcast page at
billbird.com click on the hulu plus
banner or go to huluplus.combill
that's huluplus.com bill
thank you for listening oh everybody in
scotland the
glasgow date
is on sale
i have the link up on billboard.com and
um
monday today when i guess when you're
listening to this we added a second show
at the beacon theater in um
in uh new york city uh so i'll be adding
a link for that
when i get the time i think the entire
european date is up there all those
tickets are on sale
um what else went on sale
san jose
seattle uh philly
and i think dc i think all of those are
on sale so i got a bunch of shows out
there that are all on sale oh people of
scotland it would be great if you showed
up by the way because we had we had to
really fight with them to find find some
sort of venue because they didn't think
anybody was going to show up when i was
out there so i'm at some venue that has
a lower area in an upper area
um
so
i don't know let's see if we can get a
couple people up in the upper deck too
if you can alright
just call every [ __ ] you know
and come on down all right i have at
least a new hour and a half since the
last time i was [ __ ] there would be
great if you came down saw it all right
that's the podcast for this week
don't take any [ __ ] go [ __ ] yourselves
and i'll talk to you next monday